you literally do it to enrich yourself
you're a multi-millionaire and you steal
content from small creators and you
don't give a about their rights or
what they want and then your only
justification is oh yeah you can come
chase me down and complain and try to
get my attention so I can pay you for
that I stole it's total bro
because what you're saying is I'm gonna
steal your stuff and I don't care if you
have a problem with it you can come talk
to me like that's not that's not your
right shouldn't you apologize to Vince
oh yeah it's not it's not his job to
come ask you for reparations for you
stealing from him don't you understand
that so what you're saying is that you
went digging for victims I literally
messaged one dude
okay so nobody in your production room
why don't you just apologize to Vince
vintage uh I absolutely will and I feel
I didn't get a Twitter demo I didn't get
no I didn't get nothing I feel really
bad you don't know why because all about
the oh the whole sphere of this
everything around it is to make
something good happen right and that
matter bro nice try